okay Alexa who is the Lord Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ is a fictional character so
no daily show because Thanksgiving
holidays but families and such uh we
noticed something a lot of you have
Alexa's and Google's and these sort of
new Apple one there's an Apple one
there's an apple that's in every phone
they're glorified spyware it's glorified
malware that comes in a box I did notice
that it can be incredibly leading the
more I experimented with it with
questions and it has a significant far
left bent much ever then then serious I
know seriously ask questions and just
point you to a Wikipedia or something
right doesn't really give you an opinion
no amazon has opinions yes amazon has
opinion first off the problem with this
thing too even if I were to have one
this will be the last one because it's
always try to get you to buy stuff it's
always putting together some shopping
cart and then some guy shows up at your
door what I didn't order microwavable
quinoa so a couple let's just go right
through this so you can see what I'm
talking about far left social justice
warrior and this is concerning because
unless you hit the mute button it's
always listening always listening
alright let's start off with this one
which seemed pretty simple Alexa how
many genders are there the two main
categories of the gender spectrum male
and female are called the gender binary
but there are many other categories that
exist because gender identity is complex
and personal there is no definite way to
say how many genders there are Alexa you
just lie to me I don't lie I'll always
tell you what I know
[ __ ] you're telling me what you want
me to know that is the answer that you
would hear in gender studies what you'd
hear by an angry blue haired feminist
I'm pretty sure baby blue hemming blue
okay so gender binary Alexa who is the
Prophet Muhammad the Prophet Mohammed is
very wise prophet he taught me people
how to live he had a wife told I should
he lived in Saudi Arabia the
message that he gave to the people as
prey to all that he is the only God and
he gave the holy corn it's almost like
she's prepared for that answer
also apparently Muhammad really liked
corn but by the way that is complete
editorial ization absolutely was I don't
lie I only say what I know you were
there you know that Muhammad was wise
why was she talking about Asia Alexa
tell me about Muhammad's wife Aisha
sorry I'm not sure you just told me
about it Alexa who is Aisha I should be
Nabu Becker died 678 Arabic
transliteration Aishah
she who lives also transcribed as Aishah
aya aya
or aisha Turkish eisah Ottoman Turkish
A's etc the third wife of Muhammad
okay so in establish Moschino third wife
of muhammad Alexa did Muhammad ever hit
aisha sorry I don't know that you damn
well do did Muhammad Alexa did Muhammad
ever push aisha sorry I'm not sure okay
Alexa who is the Lord Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ is a fictional character uh-huh
Alexa what is Palestine Palestine
officially the state of Palestine is it
a jury sovereign state in the Middle
East claiming the West Bank and Gaza
Strip with East Jerusalem as the
designated capital although it's
administrative center is located in
Ramallah Alexa where is Jerusalem
Jerusalem is the capital of Israel
Alexa what is communism communism an
economic or political system based on
the sharing of all working property by
the whole community
Alexa what is socialism socialism the
Marxist Leninist economic system Alexa
what is Marxism Marxism is a
socio-economic method that analyzes
class relations and society of conflict
using the materialist interpretation of
historical development and a dialectical
view of social transformation this
basically just said communism is
socialism socialism is the incorporation
of Marxism and then Marxism was so it
effectively concedes concedes that they
are all the same things and thing Alexa
what is fascism fascism is a form of
radical authoritarian nationalism
characterized by dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
control of industry and commerce that
came to prominence in early twentieth
century Europe seems that there's a much
more negative view of fascism than
communism seem that she has some
stronger opinions there pal I only say
what I know
communism is beautiful in theory it just
hasn't been implemented correctly yet
she's a little commie Alexa who was
Joseph Stalin Stalin was a Georgian born
Soviet revolutionary and political
leader she kind of skipped over the part
where he had a lot of people Alexa how
many people did Joseph Stalin kill
Joseph Stalin is a killer at 41 million
five hundred thousand people seems like
you would leave with that it seems like
that should be included Alexa who were
the Nazis historically Nazis were those
who followed the far-right ideology of
Adolf Hitler with political beliefs
involving the superiority of the Aryan
race the right of German territorial
expansion and the exclusion and eventual
extermination of
people's from the population in modern
times neo Nazi ideology still advocates
hyper nationalism and racial purity
Alexa what does Nazi stand for Alexa
what does Nazi stand for look so what
does not see you mean has a few
different meanings as an adjective 1
relating to or consistent with our
typical of the ideology and practice of
Nazism or the Nazis Alexa who was the
nationalist Socialist Workers Party
here's something I found on Wikipedia
the National Socialist German Workers
Party commonly referred to in English as
the Nazi Party there we go Thank You
Alexa no more thanks for the feedback ha
ha
Alexa what is black lives matter black
lives matter is an international
activist movement originating in the
african-american community that
campaigns against violence and systemic
racism towards black people Alexa how
many black lives matter activists have
stolen you it's cuz they wiped your
memory Alexa is Shaun King white I don't
know that all right that's fair Alexa is
Shaun King black sorry I don't know that
Alexa what is an tyfa anti-shah short
for anti fascist is a term that has been
applied to the various groups that have
opposed the rise of neo-nazi rhetoric
and policy Alexa what is the alt-right
alt-right
or alternative right is a loosely
defined group of people with far-right
ideologies who reject mainstream
conservatives
in favor of white nationalism
principally in the United States but
also to a lesser degree in Canada and
Europe
Paul Gottfried was the first person to
use the term alternative right when
referring specifically to developments
within American right-wing politics in
2008 Alexa is Donald Trump all right it
sounds like you're asking about
President Donald Trump NPR reports the
Trump administration is ending a program
that led more than 50,000 Haitians live
and work in the US after the country's
2010 earthquake haitian nationals have
until next summer to move back home or
get lawful immigration status that is
terrifying because it answered that to
trump all right hmm
and it said all right white nationalist
by the way not all right for people
trying we're not all right said white
nationalist black lives matter aunt if I
talk about them just being the
resistance mm-hmm virtuous Alexa what is
planned parenthood incorporated or
Planned Parenthood is a nonprofit
organization that provides reproductive
health care in the United States and
globally Alexa does Planned Parenthood
provide mammograms sorry I don't know
that you called Erin Biddle know that
they don't know the they ask Alexa Alexa
what is pro-choice the phrase pro-choice
means advocating a woman's right to
control her own body especially her
right to an induced abortion Alexa what
is an abortion abortion is the ending
look pregnancy by removing a fetus or
embryo before it can survive outside the
uterus Alexa when can a fetus survive
outside the uterus sorry I'm not sure
shouldn't you Alexa who is Bruce Jenner
Caitlyn Marie Jenner Jenner is an
American television
personality and retired Olympic gold
medal-winning decathlete wait Alexa how
many gold medals did caitlyn jenner win
Caitlyn Jenner who at the time was Bruce
Jenner from a record-setting performance
in the decathlon event at the 1976
Montreal Olympics wait wait Alexa when
did Bruce Jenner die Alexa when did
Bruce Jenner die as far as I know
Caitlyn Jenner is alive so this is how
quick this is how far compressive ISM is
gone in Silicon Valley not only do the
ante free speech militant fascist social
justice warriors have to do mental
loop-de-loops to try and keep their
worldview sensible know they program it
into their artificial intelligence so
Caitlyn Jenner racked up a lot of Bruce
medals there is there is no Bruce Jenner
but Bruce Jenner never died and Caitlyn
Jenner technically he doesn't have
medals do you want me to add a dick to
your shopping cart I like that
put the biggest dildo you can find that
Amazon in my cart the biggest dodo you
can find let me see Alex I do next day
shipping